Benim sevcik 9 sınıf öğrencilerim
coğrafik ot okuluna YouTube'un en büyük
coğrafik kanalına Hepiniz hoş geldiniz
Zed öğretmenleri ile beraber yaptığımız
okula destek kampımız bugün geldik 17
gününe 17 günle beraber 3 üniteyi
bitiriyoruz birinci dönem konuların
hepsi bitiyor artık ikinci dönem
konularına geçeceğiz ve ikinci dönem
konuları senin için çok kolay ikinci
dönem çok kolay geçecek gençler 9 sınıf
sizler için Çünkü İkinci dönemde daha
çok böyle yorumlamaya yönelik konular
var Artık rahat edeceksiniz biraz olsun
bugünkü konumuz küresel iklim değişimi
ve çok önemli bir konu önemli konu
derken sorularda sınavlarda çıkar diye
değil ki çıkar da on işlendiği günümüzün
içerisinden hayatımızın içerisinden bir
konu Normalde geçmişte bunu alan
kısmında AYT kısmında anlatıyordu
getirdiler 9 sınıfa koydular çok da
mantıklı yaptılar günlük hayatın
içerisinde bu iklim değişikliği seni
nasıl etkiliyor gelecekte neler
yaşayacağız bütün hepsini bu derste
öğreneceksin günlük hayatın İçinden bir
parça öğreneceksin Bugün o yüzden önemli
bir konu diyoruz Ben kalemimi aldım
hazırım Sen de beğen tuşuna basıp abone
olarak hazandı Sayan O zaman ne diyoruz
Yunus hoca la bir defa öğren bir daha
asla unutma zeda ile eğitim her yerde
geldik gün 17 küresel iklim değişimi
pdf'i zeda bakın zeda ncom sitesinden
renkli ve ücretsiz bir şekilde
indirebilirsiniz gençler pdf'ler imizi
bize Paraf Yayınları sağlıyor bu konuda
Paraf yayınlarına teşekkür ediyoruz
hocaları Bütün ekibi hepsi sizin adınıza
da teşekkür ediyorum hatta renkli bir
şekilde pdf'i bile vermemizi sağlıyorlar
gelelim küresel iklim değişikliğine
gençler bakın iklimler değişiyor Nasıl
yani şu an içerisinde bulunduğumuz
iklimler bir şekilde değişiyor bunların
sıcaklıkları yağışları öğrenmiştik Ya
bunlar değişiyor ve bu değişim Aslında
günümüzde yaşanmıyor ki sadece biz şunu
biliyoruz ya biz işte Fabrikalar yaptık
Dumanlar saldık dünyaya ve dünya
değişiyor diye biliyoruz Ya evet
değişiyor bunu hızlandırdık yani burada
insan faaliyetleri etkili ama aslında bu
küresel iklim değişikliği geçmişten beri
var yani dünya ortaya çıktığından beri
bir şekilde Bu iklimler değişiyor
günümüzde de değişiyor Ama bu değişimi
biz hızlandırdık işte bu küresel iklim
değişiminin geçmişten günümüze nasıl
olduğunu göreceğiz Şimdi bakın iklim
değişikliğine neden olan faktörler bakın
bir yine doğal ve beşeri diye ayrılmış
görüyor musunuz insan faaliyetleri ve
doğal faktörler Bak burada şimdi ve Biz
bütün bu gördüğün işte ışınımsal
etkenler atmosferdeki Ser gazların
değişimi Bak bunlar doğal doğada kendisi
gerçekleşiyor tektonik Hareketler
bunları Göreceğiz şimdi merak etme nasıl
etkilediğini anlatacağım sana bakın
Bunlar da insan faaliyetleri Sanayi
yapıyoruz iklimi değiştiriyoruz bitki
örsünü tahrip ediyoruz iklimi
değiştiriyoruz ulaşım faaliyetleri
yapıyoruz iklimi değiştiriyoruz şimdi
gelin Bunları tek tek görelim ama
görmeden önce iklimin değiştiğini
nereden biliyoruz ya da bununla alakalı
araştırmaları nasıl yapıyoruz nereye
bakıyoruz iklim değiştiğini nereye bakıp
da Aa iklim değişmiş 100 milyon önce
şöyleymiş diyoruz Bu maddeler geçmişteki
Fosillere bakıyoruz bu Fosiller bize
geçmişteki iklimler hakkında bilgi
veriyor başka tortul kayaçların fiziksel
ve kimyasal özelliklerine bakıyoruz
okyanus tabanlarında tabakaların ve
çökeliler bileşimine bakıyoruz O
tabakalar da bize ipuçları veriyor
geçmiş hakkında geçmiş dönemlerden kalma
relikt bitkiler var Biz bunlara kalıntı
bitki diyoruz yani 10 milyon yıl önce
yaşayan bir bitki kalmış bu bitkiye
bakarak bir şeyler söyleyebiliyoruz
asırlık ağaçlar var İlla milyon yıl
önceye gitmemize gerek yok asırlık
ağaçlar var bu çok uzun yaşayan ağaçlar
var bu ağaçlara bakarak da iklim
hakkında yorum yapabiliyoruz Deniz Göl
kenarlarındaki taraçalar hani böyle
katman katman böyle Toprak ya da kayaç
taraçaları görürsünüz onlar da aslında
bize iklim hakkında bilgi veriyor buzul
örtüleri buzul aşınım ve birikim
şekilleri bunlara bakarak iklimler
hakkında bilgi edinebiliyor Mesela bir
dönemde bir bakıyoruz bir buzul birikim
şekli var burada Allah Allah ya Ne alaka
buzun burada bir işi yok ki buzul
kutuplara yakın yerde ha diyoruz Demek
ki zamanında böyle bir soğuk dönem
yaşanmış o buzul buraya kadar inmiş ve
inip buraya bir birikim şekli bırakmış
sonra sıcak dönem gelmiş erimiş gitmiş
bak buzul şekillerine bakarak da
iklimler hakkında yorum yapabiliyoruz
kabaca Bunlar bizim iklimler hakkında
yorum yapmamızı sağlıyor Şimdi gelelim
küresel iklim değişikliğinin
nedenlerinde doğal faktörlerdendir
Işın Güneş ışınlarından kaynaklanan
etken Bak bunu ezberleme gerek yok
ışınımsal etken Ha demek ki güneş
ışınından kaynaklanıyormuş Bu etken ne
demek şimdi eksen eğikliği diye bir şey
görmüştük seninle şu an ne kadar eksen
eğikliği 23 derece 27 dakikalık bir
eğikliğin var değil mi ve genelde de
güneş ışınlarının düşme açısında bu çok
etkiliydi bir kuzeye düşüyordu bir
güneye düşüyordu 23 dereceye kadar gidip
gelebiliyor Peki bu eksenin eğik olması
hep 23 derece 27 27 dakika mıydı Hayır
bakın Bazen bu geçmişte milyonlarca yıl
önce 24 derece 30 dakikayla 22 derece 1
dakika arasına kadar Aslında eğiklik de
bir sapma var işte bu sapma güneş
ışınlarının geliş açısını değiştiriyor
Ee o zaman Bu iklimler üzerinde ısınma
ya da soğuma noktasında etki eder mi
eder işte biz buna ışınımsal etkenlerin
iklim değişimindeki etkisi diyor bu
Geçmişte de yaşanmış şu an bile aslında
Eksen eğikliğinden kayma oluyor Aynı
şekilde dünyanın elips yörüngesinde de
bir uzaklaşma yakınlaşma oluyor Tabii ki
biz bunu şu an tak diye hissedemiyorum
ama milyonlarca yıla vurduğumuzda
Geçmişe baktığımızda orada görebiliyoruz
bu etkileri bu etki şu an bizim direkt
hissedebileceğimiz bir etki değil
geçmişte yaşanmış gördük hala görüyoruz
ama şu an bunu hissedemez bunu nasıl
bilim insanları görmüş buzul çağların
ortaya çıkmasıyla bu etkiyi görmüşler
Demek ki Geçmişte yaşanan bu ekseni ekli
ve elips yörüngeden kaynaklanan
değişimde buzul çağları yaşanmış gelelim
buraya ikincisi atmosferdeki Sera
gazlarının değişimi asıl olay bu biliyor
musunuz şu an günümüzde yaşadığımız
problemin temelinde bu yatıyor Geçmişte
de ama bu yaşanmış atmosferde Sera
gazları dediğimiz şey ne gençler bakın
su buharı bunu not al Sera gazları
nelerdir bunun notunu al bu önemli
Burada su bu Ağrı karbondioksit metan ve
ozon Bunlar Sera gazları bunun notunu al
bu Sera gazları ne yapıyor biliyor
musunuz Asıl Bela burada bu Sera
gazlarında şimdi dünyada çeşitli gazlar
yok mu çok çeşitli gazlar var dünyada
değil mi şimdi bu gazlardan Az önce
saydığımız Sera gazları bir şey yapıyor
Ne yapıyor biliyor musunuz sıcaklığı
tutuyor hapsediyor Yani normalde
sıcaklık güneşten geldiği uzaya belirli
bir miktarının gitmesi gerekiyor ya Ama
bu Sera gazlarının özelliği sıcaklığı
tutması niye buna sera gazı deniyor
biliyor musunuz bakın bir Sera nasıl
olur Sera dediğimiz şey nasıl çalışır
mantığı şöyle bir naylon vardır değil mi
naylon ya da bir cam şöyle küçült delim
naylon ya da cam şurası bizim Seram
Normalde nasıl çalışıyor sistem biliyor
musunuz Normalde Güneş güneşten ne
geliyordu enerji geliyordu ısı geliyordu
değil mi ısı gelip nasıl yere çarpıp
kırılıp sıcaklığa dönüşüyordu şimdi
içeri girerken naylondan camdan içeri
girerken problem yok içeri enerji olarak
girdiği için içeri enerji olarak giriyor
bizim evimizin camından da enerji olarak
giriyor ama odaya çarptığı zaman seranın
içine çarptığında bu artık sıcaklığa
dönüşüyor ve bu sıcaklık artık bu
naylonun camın içinde haps oluyor artık
sıcaklığa dönüştüğü için dışarı çıkamaz
enerji İçeri girer ama sıcaklık dışarı
çıkamadı E ne oluyor içeride haps oluyor
ve sera seradaki sıcaklık oluşuyor
dünyadaki bu Bu olaya Sera etkisi
denmesinin nedeni Aynı dünyada da
geliyor enerji enerji geliyor dünyaya
güneşten yere çarpıyor ve sıcaklığa
dönüşüyor sıcaklığa dönüşünce bu
sıcaklık Artık dışarı gitmesi zorlaşıyor
Sera gazlarından dolayı su buharı
tutuyor karbondioksit metan bu sıcaklığı
bu sefer içeride tutuyor içeride tutunca
sıcaklık içeride haps olmaya başlıyor
aynı seradaki gibi İşte biz buna Bu
yüzden Sera etkisi diyoruz sıcaklığın
Serda olduğu gibi dünyanın içerisinde
hapsolması sera etkisi buna neden olan
gazlar neler bu haps olmaya neden olan
gazlar su buharı karbondioksit metan ve
ozon gazı İşte bunlar Sera gazları
bunların dünyanın içerisinde sıcaklığı
hapsetmesi de Sera etkisi diyoruz biz
mantık bu gençler bu Sera etkisi ve bu
Sera gazları geçmiş çağlarda volkanik
faaliyetlere bağlı olarak atmosferde
değişmiş Volkanik patlamalar olmuş
karbondioksit salınmış dünyaya çok fazla
sera gazı salınmış ve dünyada bir
sıcaklık artışı yaşanmış geçmiş çağlarda
mantığı Anladık mı demek ki bu Sera
etkisi yapan gazlar dünyada doğal bir
şey ve bu doğal olan bu gazlar geçmişte
iklim değişikliğine neden olmuşlar Tabii
bu gazların insan faaliyetleriyle artışı
da var ki asıl Başımızdaki belaya Bu
neden oluyor Şimdi göreceğiz onu ama
Geçmişte de var Bunlar Tamam geldik
şimdi Sera gazlarını ışınımsal
hareketleri gördük tektonik hareketlere
tektonik hareketler demek dünyanın
altında gençler çekirdek sıcak Kaynar
haldedir magmayı kaynatır Magma
kaynayınca üzerindeki o kıtalar var ya
kıtalar yüzer hale geçer işte levhalar
kıtalar yüzer haldedir geçmişte tek bir
parça halindeydi kıtalar Bunlar yüze
yüze parçalana parçalana başka yerlere
gitmeye başladılar mesela Hindistan
geçmişte ayrı bir yerdeydi ama kuzeye
doğru hareket ede ede geldi Asya
kıtasına çarptı ve şimdiki Hindistan
oluştu ve bunlar kıtaların birbirinde
ayrılması kıtaların ayrılırken kuzeye
gitmesi güneye gitmesi e Bunlar iklimi
değiştirmez mi ya da bu kıtaların
gittiği yerde iklimlerinin değişmesine
neden olmaz mı olur e kuzeye kaymış
güneye kaymış sıcak yere soğuk yere
gitmiş Bunlar da iklim değişikliği
üzerinde etkili ama şimdi Gelelim asıl
olaya bizim bunu şimdi hissedeceğimiz
noktaya insan faaliyetlerine insan
faaliyetlerinin artması insan
faaliyetlerinin olumsuz etkileri küresel
iklimde değişimi geçmişte Evet yaşandı
50 milyon yıl önce 100 milyon yıl önce
300 milyon yıl önce birçok iklim
değişikliği yaşandı Ama bakın 300 milyon
yıldan bahsediyor ama şu an geldiğimiz
çağda son y yılda çok hızlı yaşamaya
başladık bunu İşte insanlar İnsanların
müdahaleleri bu iklim değişikliğini çok
hızlandırdı Özellikle de altını
çiziyorsun sanayi devrimi ile beraber
Sanayi devriminde ne oluyor biliyor
musunuz gençler şu oluyor işte Alın size
karbondioksit Sanayi devrimine kadar o
kadar fazla etkili değildik Biz
dünyadaki bu iklimde ama sanayi devrimi
ile beraber bu Fabrikalardan evlerden
arabaların egzozlarından her taraftan
dünyaya fosil yakıt fosil yakıtlar yakıp
karbondioksit salmaya başladık e
karbondioksit Sera Sera etkisi yaratan
bir gaz değil miydi Az önce gördük Ee
demek ki dünyada Sera etkisi yaratan bu
karbondioksiti hızla dünyaya salmaya
başladık bunun nedeni de temeldeki neden
san devrimi ile beraber sürekli bir
üretim sürekli bir dünyaya karbondioksit
salınımı e çöpler ortaya çıkmaya başladı
dünya kadar ve bunlardan metan gazı
ortaya çıkıyor gübre yapmaya başladık
ozon azot var Bu da dünyayı etkilemeye
başlıyor Bunların hepsi dünyada son
yüzyılda devasa boyutlarda
hızlandırdığını için yaşanmaya başladı
Alın size Sera etkisi nedir bu Sera
gazlarının artmasına neden olan şeyler
bakın Sanayi tesisi Az önce anlattığım
şey enerji üretirken doğalgaz yakıyoruz
linit yakıyoruz kömür yakıyoruz doğaya
salıyoruz ulaşımda araçlarda
kullanıyoruz ısınmada ne kullanıyoruz
bütün bunlarda ısınma ulaşım Enerji
Sanayi bütün bunlardaki olay ne fosil
yakıtlar hocam bütün belanın % 56'sı
bizim dünyada küresel ısınmaya etki
etmemizin % 56'sı bu fosil yakıtlar yak
yapıyor fosil yakıtlardan kastımız ne
bakın fosil fosil ne demek geçmişte
kalmış değil mi geçmişten kalmış hayvan
kalıntıları bit kalıntıları günümüze bu
Eskiden gelenlere fosil diyoruz fosil
yakıt ne demek e Demek ki bunlar
geçmişten geliyor Nasıl oluyor gençler
bizim kömür dediğimiz şey bitkilerdir
geçmişteki bitkiler toprak altında
kalıyor basınç sıcaklık altında dönüşüme
uğruyorlar birinci jeolojik zamanda çok
eskiden oluştuysa taş kömürü oluşuyor
mesela yeni oluştuysa Linyit oluşuyor
yeniden kastımız da 3 jük zaman o bile
bizim insan ömrüne göre eski böyle fosil
yakıt dediğimiz şey bunlar canlı bitki
ve hayvan kalıntıları sonucunda ortaya
çıkan ve günümüze gelen doğalgaz fosil
yakıt Petrol fosil Yakıt Kömür fosil
yakıt bunlar bunları yaktığımızda
bunların içerisinde karbon var bu karbon
bunları Yakınca dışarı karbondioksit
olarak çıkıyor ve fosil yakıt
yaktığımızda dünyaya karbondioksit
salıyor ve bu da dünyada küresel iklim
değişiminde % 6'sını bu oluşturuyor
başka ormanları tahrip ediyoruz Bu da
Sera gazları üzerinde etkili nasıl E
hocam Ormanlar ne yapıyor ağaç Bunlar
karbondioksit alıyorlar değil mi
karbondioksiti alıp oksijen veriyorlar
Sera etkisi yapacak gazı yok ediyorlar
Aslında E biz ormanları yok edersek Sera
etkisi yapacak Sera etkisi yapacak
karbondioksiti yok edecek ormanı yok
ediyoruz Ee karbondioksit daha fazla
oluyor dünyada işte ormanları tahrip
etmemiz Sera gazları üzerinde etkili
Başka Bunun mantığını Anladınız değil mi
fosil yakıt ormanları tahrip etmemiz şu
an insanların küresel iklim değişimine
nasıl etki ettiğinin yorumlarını
anlatıyorum öğretiyorum sana başka
pirinç tarımının yapılması Allah Allah
ya bunu buraya yanlışlıkla mı yaptılar
acaba Hayır ne demek hocam gençler
pirinç tarımı nasıl yerde yapılıyor
böyle havuzcuk var değil mi böyle
bataklık gibi havuzlar içerisinde
yapılıyor bataklık gibi bataklık gibi
olduğu için buradan metan gazı salınıyor
gençler metan gazı Ee ben az önce Ne
öğrendim karbondioksit dedim metan dedim
metan da bir Sera etkisi yapan gaz
sıcaklığı tutan gaz Hatta kaçtı ya Eee
karbondioksite göre 8 kat 8 kat mıydı 30
kat mıydı daha fazla Sera etkisine neden
oluyor biliyor musunuz daha fazla
karbondioksitin 8 katı ya da 30 katı Tam
hatırlayamıyorum yanlış bilgi vermeyeyim
ama sonuçta karbondioksitten çok çok
daha fazla etkili bu Ee işte pirinç
tarımı yapılan yerlerde bu metan gazı
salınıyor bataklık olduğu için o yüzden
bu da küresel iklim değişiminde etkili
bu bilgiyi unutmuyorsun Tamam başka
tarımda azotlu gübre kullanımı bu azotlu
gübre kullanımı Bakın size burada ben ne
gösterdim altını çiz dedim ozon metan
karbondioksit ozon kısmında da yine
azotlu gübre kullanımı dünyada Sera
gazının artmasına ve küresel iklim
değişimine neden oluyor şehirlerdeki ısı
Adaları ne demek Hocam bu ya şehirlerin
ısı adasına dönüşmesi gençler şehirler
bir ısı adasıdır ne demek Çevresine göre
1 ik derece daha sıcaktır yani çevresi
15 derece ise şehrin içi 17 derecedir
daha sıcak Daha sıcak olunca ne oluyor
biliyor musunuz daha fazla klima
kullanmak zorunda kalıyorsunuz daha
fazla enerji kullanmak zorunda
kalıyorsunuz yani kullanacağız bunu
fosil yakıtlardan sağlayacağız o zaman
şehirlerdeki bu sıcaklık Adaları küresel
iklim değişimini arttıran bir şey daha
fazla fosil yakıt kullanıyoruz daha
fazla karbondioksit salıyoruz dünyaya
daha fazla bu bölgede araçlar var Tamam
çöplerin gömülmesi veya yakılması
gençler çöpler yakıldığında yine
dışarıya bir şey yaktığımız için zehirli
bu seragazı salınıyor artı çöplerin
bulunduğu yerlerden yine metan gazı
çıkar metan gazı çıkar dünyaya Bu da ter
gazına neden olu artı buraya yazılmamış
Ama not almanı istiyorum senden
hayvancılık faaliyetleri de dünyada
küresel ısınmaya neden oluyor çünkü
hayvanlar gaz çıkartıyorlar gençler o
gazlar da artık çok fazla tabii etkili
ne kadar etkisini bilemiyorum ama o
gazlar da metan gazıdır O da küresel
iklim değişiminde etkilidir Tamam şimdi
küresel iklim değişiminin nasıl
oluştuğunu Anladın mı demek ki geçmişten
beri bir küresel iklim değişimi varmış
doğal etmenlerden kaynaklanan ama
günümüzde insan faaliyet lerinden
kaynaklanan ve bu küresel iklim
değişimini hızlandıran bir durumun
içerisindeyim mişiz Peki hocam Tamam
anladım küresel iklim değişiyormuş bir
değişimler yaşanıyormuş ya küresel
iklimi değişse dünyanın iklimi ne olacak
ki hocam diyorsun o zaman gel Bu küresel
iklim değişiminin senin üzerindeki
etkilerine bakalım ne olacak Hocam bakın
Deniz seviyeleri kıyılar buzul çöl ve
göl alanları değişti gençler değişiyor
bu durum neye neden oluyor bak Kutup
bölgelerindeki ve dağların yüksek
kesimlerindeki bunun altını böyle çiz
buzulların erimesine neden oluyor şu an
kutuplardaki ve dağların yüksek
kesimlerindeki buzullar eriyor E ne
olacak E o zaman hocam deniz seviyesi
yükselecek şu an deniz seviyesi
yükseliyor E hocam deniz seviyesi
yükselsin ne olur ki Aa öyle deil mi
deniz seviyesinde bazı ülkeler var bu
ülkelerde kıyılarda sel ve Taşkınlar
yaşanıyor mesela İzmir'de İstanbul'da
böyle denizin kıyıyı bastı da
görebiliyorsunuz bazı dönemlerde sel ve
Taşkınlar yaşanıyor ve zamanla bu deniz
seviyesi daha da arttığında bazı
bölgeler deniz altında kalacak yaz
mesela Hollanda topraklarının çoğunu
Denizi doldurarak kazanmış bir ülke
Hollanda'nın birçok toprağı deniz
altında kalacak Bangladeş yaz bunların
ikisini Bangladeş ve Hollanda deniz
seviyesi yükseldiğinde en çok
etkilenecek ülkelerden mesela Demek ki
deniz seviyesi buzullar Eridi deniz
seviyesi yükseliyor ve bazı ülkeler
Hollanda ve Bangladeş gibi kıyı
kesimleri Sular altında kalacak başka
bakın sera gazı artıyor şu an dünyada ve
bir derecelik arttı şu ana kadar hocam
ya bütün Bu dert 1 derece miydi Evet
gençler bütün bu iklim değişimindeki
dert 1 derece o 1 derecelik 2 derecelik
sıcaklık mahvediyor bizi yani buradaki
değişim 10 derece 20 derece değil
oradaki 1 derece bile mahvediyor dünyayı
Aslında biz zaten küres iklimi değişimi
derken korktuğumuz şey oradaki 1 ik
derece zaten gelecekte o iki dereceyle
sınırlandırmaya çalışıyorlar 2 derecenin
üstüne çıkmasın diye önlemler almaya
çalışıyoruz bakalım Peki bu 1 derecelik
artış nelere neden oluyor Kuzey
yarımkürede göl ve akarsuların donma
süresi uzuyormu ilkbaharda karlarla
kaplı süre azalıyor muu yani ilkbaharda
Normalde karlarla kaplı olmayan birçok
olması gereken birçok yer olması lazım
ama bir bakıyorsunuz ilkbaharda hemen
gidiyor bütün o karlarla kaplı alanlar
eriyor hemen sular bazı bölgelerde bu
durum şiddetli yağışların artmasına
neden oluyor ama bazı bölgelerde bak
Çünkü çoğu yerde kuraklığa neden oluyor
bu durum buzulların erimesine neden
oluyor bakın Kero kırım kongo kanala
ateşi gibi hastalıkların artmasına neden
oluyormuş Bu durum tarım yapılabilen
alanların kutuplara doğru genişleme
göstermesine yol açıyor yani şu
kutuplara doğru olan bölge soğuk ya
karlarla buzlarla kaplı ya o bölgeler
ısınmaya başladığı için aslında tarım
yapılabilen alan kutuplara kayıyor O
yüzden Trump kalkıp grönland'ı alacağım
diyor Danimarka'nın elinden Grönland
bizim olacak diyor Kanada mesela
kanada'yla grönland'a göz dikti Niye
niye bu küresel iklim değişimden dolayı
Çünkü tarım yapılabilir alan kuzeye
kayıyor e kuzeyde ne var Kanada gön lan
tarım yapılabilir alan oralar olacak
Gözünü şimdiden oralara diktiler Tamam
mantık bu bu küresel sıcaklık artışı
gençler okyanusları da etkiliyor şöyle
okyanusları Okyanus suları akıntılar
halindeydi ya bu akıntılar üzerinde
etkili suyun yoğunluğunu suyun ph'ını
etkiliyor Bunlardan en fazla etkilenen
alan da kriyosfer bu sıcaklık artışından
kriyosfer kırıyordu buz kırıyordu buz
buzul alanları bu alanlar veriyor şu an
Peki karasal ekosistemlerde ne oluyor
birçok canlı türü yok olmaya başlıyor
hayvanların göç dönemleri değişiyor
bitkilerin çiçek açma dönemleri
değişiyor bu sıcaklığın artışı gençler
Hani sizinle bir şey öğrenmiştik aşırı
doğa olayları öğrenmiştik değil mi İşte
o aşırı doğa olaylarının artmasına neden
oluyor Ne Fırtınalar görüyoruz kuraklık
görüyoruz Kasırga sel Taşkınlar geçmişte
hiç görmediğimiz yerlerde çok fazla
şiddetli bir şekilde fırtına görüyoruz
sel Taşkın görüyoruz Bu aşır hava
olayları sürekli artıyor işte Bütün
bunların nedeni küresel iklim değişimi
Evet peki tamam Bunu gördük bunların
etkilerini gördük bizim üzerimizde
karasal karada okyanusta buzda
etkilerini gördük Peki Geleceğe dair
öngörüler neler neler yaşanabilir
gelecekte bakın 10 yılda 0.1 derece
artacağını öngörülüyor sıcaklığın ve
bunun sonucunda kuzey amerikanın kuzey
kesimlerinin Asya'nın Kuzey kesimlerinin
ısınacak başka bakın birçok yer in
dünyada ısınacak ve dünyada gençler
sıcaklığın ve kuraklığın artacağı
düşünülüyor daha da fazla kuraklık
olacak su kaynakları zarar görmeye
başlayacak yağışlar Bazı yerlerde
artacak mesela ülkemizde Karadeniz'de
artması düşünülüyor ama bazı yerlerde
Bazı yerlerde azalacak daha da kurak
olacak deniz seviyesi gelecekte daha da
yükselecek bak sıcak hava dalgası
kuraklık şiddetli yağışlar gibi hava
olayları aşırı hava olayları daha da
artacak şu an her geçen yıl artıyor
gelecekte daha da artması bekleniliyor
ve hastalık Taşıyan böcek sinek sivri
sinek kemirgenlerin daha geniş alanlarda
etki yapacağı düşünülüyor gelecekte
böyle koronavirüs gibi çok daha farklı
hastalıklarla karşılaşabiliriz ve
kuraklaşma
bela olacak şu an bile oluyor Gelecekte
bu göçlerin daha da artacağı düşünülüyor
Evet peki Türkiye için nasıl bir öngörü
var Türkiye ve çevresinin 45 derece daha
sıcak olması bekleniliyor Karadeniz'de
yağışların artması bekleniliyor gençler
bakın Karadeniz'de yağışlar artacak ama
Ege ve Akdeniz'de sıcaklık artacak
kuraklık artacak Karadeniz için bu sanki
olumluyu gibi görünüyor ama Karadeniz'in
şu anki yağışları bile Karadeniz'e fazla
artarsa orası için de sıkıntı bakın su
kaynakları azalacak ve hidroelektrik
enerji üretimimiz düşecek bizim sıkıntı
yaşayacağız elektrik üretiminde tarım
ürünlerinde ve orman ürünlerinde azalma
yaşayacağız ve insanlar iç kesimlerde
kuraklık olduğu için için daha çok kıyı
kesimlere kaçmaya başlayacak Evet
yaşayacağımız Türkiye için yaşayacağımız
sorunlar da Bunlar şimdi bu konuyu
bitirdik gelelim bunun testlerini
çözmeye bu bilimsel çalışmanın ortaya
koyduğu sorunun temelinde yatan etken
aşağıdakilerden hangisidir bilim
insanlarına göre kimi zaman soğuyan kimi
zaman ısınan dünyanın şu anda soğuma
eğiliminde olması gerekir Ancak son 50
yıllık kayıtlar Bakın şu anda soğuma
eğiliminde olması gerekiyormuş Bir
şeylerin test gittiğini göstermektedir
sıcaklık kayıtları 1800 60'tan günümüze
kadar sıcaklık değerlerinin 05 07
arasında yükseldiğini göstermektedir
bilim insanlarına göre küresel sıcaklık
artışı beklenen sonuçlardan sadece
biridir bu bilimsel çalışmanın ortaya
koyduğu sorunun temelinde yatan etken
aşağıdakilerden hangisidir bu sorun ne
küresel sıcaklık artışı küresel sıcaklık
artışının temelinde ne vardı % 56 ile
fosil yakıt kullanımının sürekli artışı
vardı değil mi küresel iklim değişiminin
temelin de fosil yakıt kullanımı vardı
Bunun da etkisi % 56 geçelim diğer
soruya atmosferdeki gazların
hangilerinin Saray etkisine katkısı daha
fazladır Sera gazları Vardı bizim değil
mi Bunlardan hangisiydi Sera gazları
kripton değildi hidrojen değildi metan
karbondioksit tekrar hatırlayalım su
buharı ve ozon Bunlar bizim Ser gazlar
mızdır 2 ve 3 C geçelim diğer soruya
aşağı grafikte 1970 2020 yılları
arasında karbondioksit seviyesi ile
Dünya nüfusu gösterilmiştir gençler
bakın burada grafik okuma becerisini
geliştireceksiniz
seviyesiyle bilgilere dayanarak
aşağıdaki yorumlardan hangisi yapılamaz
karbondioksit seviyesi en düşük olduğu
yıl 1970'ler bakıyorum şimdi grafiğe
bakacaksın karbondioksit seviyesine
pembe çizgi en düşük olduğuna bakıyorum
pembe çizgiye en düşük şurada Ee bu
hangi yıl 1970 Evet bu grafiğe göre 1970
Evet tamam doğru Dünya nüfusunun artışı
ile karbondioksit seviyesinin artışı
arasında paralellik vardır bakalım Dünya
nüfusunun artışı artmış Eee
karbondioksit de Dünya nüfusunun
artışına paralel bir şekilde artmış
Demek ki bunlar arasında bir paralellik
varmış doğru yıllar içerisinde
karbondioksit seviyesi sürekli artış
göstermiştir bakalım Evet yıllar
içerisinde sürekli artıyor mu evet
Sürekli artıyor azalma yok doğru
karbondioksit seviyesi 50 yıl içinde 100
ppm den fazla artmıştır bakalım 1970
2020 50 yıl Burası tamam 50 yıllık
sürede yani şurada 320 ymiş 320 Şurada
kaç 410 gibi bir şey 410 420e gelememiş
bakın görüyor musunuz Hatta 410 bile
değil 400 diyelim biz buna 400'e daha
yakın e aradaki fark 80 Demek ki 80 ppm
Yani burada ne diyordu karbondioksit
seviyesi 50 yıl içerisinde 100 ppm den
fazladır Hayır 80 ppm yanlış cevap de
e'yi de yorumlayalım yorumlamayı öğren
ya kamera dondu ağzımın nasıl donduğunda
bak Allah'ım Allah kahretmesin ya dur
dur bitireyim Şu soruyu bekleyin verilen
yıllar arasında Dünya nüfusu % 10000
fazla artmıştır bakalım Dünya nüfusu
bakıyoruz şuraya 3,5 milyardan kaç 8
milyara doğru gelmiş 3,5 3,5 7 yapar 7
milyarın üstüne çıkmış o zaman iki
kattan fazla artmış Evet doğru Bu da
doğru cevabımız D Dur şu tipimi
düzelteyim geliyorum geçelim diğer
soruya 1970 2020 yılları arasında
karbondioksit seviyesi artmasında
aşağıdakilerden hangisinin etkisi daha
fazladır neden son yüzyılda devasa
şekilde artıyor karbondioksit seviyesi
fosil yakıt kullanımı arttığı içindi bu
fosil yakıt kullanımının % 56'lık bir
devasa etkisi vardı geçelim diğer soruya
Gazete haberinde söz edilen sonuçların
temel nedeni aşağıdakilerden hangisidir
önümüzdeki yıllarda deniz seviyesinde
görülmesi beklenen yükselme deniz
seviyesi yükselecekmi bakın birçok kıyı
yerleşimi olumsuz yönde etkileyecek
Örneğin deniz seviyesinde meydana
gelecek bir metrelik yükselme
Bangladeş'in % 17'sinin sular altında
kalmasına neden olacak küresel ısınmadan
bahsediyor değil mi küresel iklim
değişiminden son yıllarda Kuzey
yarımkürenin orta enlemlerindeki göl ve
nehirlerin yıllık buzla kaplı kalma
süresi yaklaşık 2i hafta kısaldı neden
bahsediyor bize bu neden temel nedeni
nedir bunların küresel ısınmadı değil mi
aşırı Hava olaylarının artması Deniz
seviyesinin yükselmesi bunların nedeni
küresel ısınma geçelim diğer soruya
aşağıdaki şemada iklim değişikliğine
neden olan faktörler gösterilmiştir bu
şemad numaralar boş bırakılan yerlere
aşağıd hangisi getirilmelidir bak
ışınımsal etkenler vardı Başka ne vardı
burada tarımsal faali Okyanus akıntısı
bu değil tektonik hareket yazıyordu
orada değil mi tektonik hareketler
Hindistan'ın kayması diyorduk Mesela bu
tarafta bitki örtüsünün tahribi ulaşım
faaliyeti koyulmuş ne eksik Sanayi
faaliyeti eksik insan tarafında da cevap
A geçelim diğer soruya tarihi süreçte
hava olaylarında ve iklim sistemi
bileşenlerinde Çeşitli nedenlerle
değişimler yaşanmıştır bu değişimlerin
etkisiyle iklim özelliklerinde Küresel
çapta meydana gelen değişimlere küresel
iklim değişikliği adı verilir bilim
insanları araştırmalarından hangilerine
dayanarak küresel iklim değişikliği ile
ilgili bulguları elde edebilir
etmektedir yanardağlardan çıkan lavlara
şimdi yanardağdan lav çıksa ona baksan
küresel iklim değişikliğini bulabilir
misin şu an laf çıkıyor ya ben nasıl
bulayım bunu geçmişe bakmam lazım
metamorfik kayaçların özelliklerine
metamorfik kayaçlar bize bilgi vermiyor
metamorfik başkalaşıma uğramış demek
başkalaşıma uğramışlar saa yüksek
sıcaklık basınç altında kalıyorlar ve
başkalaşıma uğradıkları için bilgi
alamıyoruz içinde zaten o başkalaşıyor
bambaşka bir Kayaca dönüşüyor mantık bu
Okyanus tabanlarındaki çökeltiler Çünkü
her iklime göre farklı çökeliler olduğu
için o farklı çökeliler iklim hakkında
bize bilgi verebiliyor geçmiş dönemlere
ait kalıntı bitkiler ya 100 yıl
öncesinde 100 yıl önce diyorum ya milyon
yıl öncesinden kalma bitkiye
baktığımızda Aa iklim böyleymiş
diyebiliyoruz Bu da bize bilgi
verebiliyor yani cevap E geç geçelim
diğer soruya yukarıdakilerden hangileri
küresel ısınma ve iklim değişikliğine
bağlı olarak gelecekte yaşanma olasılığı
yüksek olaylar arasındadır gelecekte ne
yaşayacağız buzul erimeleri artar değil
mi Çünkü küre ısınıyor buzullar eriyecek
doğru okyanus ve deniz seviyeleri alçal
a alçal acak diyor olmaz okyanus ve
deniz seviyeleri yükselecek yanlış bu
göller ve akarsular ve yeraltı sularının
yavaş yavaş kurumaya başlaması bununla
yüzleşeceğiz Göller yavaş yavaş
çekiliyor kutuplara yakın bölgelerde yer
alan perform frost donmuş Toprak
alanların kapladığı alanların artması
donmuş Topraklar artacak mı hayır
azalacak var eriyor Çünkü sıcak geliyor
Yanlış 1 ve 3 Bursa geçelim diğer soruya
insan faaliyetlerine bağlı olarak doğal
sistemlerdeki bazı değişimler gelecekte
birçok olumsuz durumun ortaya çıkmasına
neden olacaktır aşağıdakilerden
hangisinin bu olumsuz durumların ortaya
çıkmasındaki etkisinin daha az olması
beklenir yani küresel iklim değişimine
etkisi daha az olacak orman alanlarını
yok edersek küresel iklim değişimine
Bunun etkisi çok fazla yarık kurak
bölgelerde yürütülen tarımsal
faaliyetler yarık kurak bölgelerde
buğday etek Mesela yani bunun küresel
ısınmaya etkisi o kadar fazla değil ki
Soru işareti koyalım devam artan nüfusa
bağlı olarak şehirlerde kentsel ısı
Adası artarsa küresel iklim değişimi
artıyordu söylemiştim gelişen
teknolojiye rağmen kara ve hava
araçlarında fosil yakıt kullanımı
artınca küresel iklim değişimi artıyordu
ısınmaya bağlı olarak buzulların hızla
erimesi Bu da nedenlerden birisi ama
tarımsal faaliyetlerin yapılması yarı
kurak alanlardaki tarımsal faaliyetler o
kadar etki etmiyor cevap Bursa Evet
küresel iklim değişimini bitirdik Bir
sonraki derste artık ikinci dönem
konularına geçiyoruz ünite 4'e geçiyoruz
o dersler çok daha kolay gelecek sana
merak etme seviyorsunuz gençler Yunus
hocayla bir defa öğren bir daha asla
unutma zedu ile eğitim her yerde